we're about to meditate for two months
straight I signed up to do two months of
meditation I don't really know much
about meditation in general so we're
gonna meditate for about two months
every day and see how it goes
Transcendental Meditation is one thing
it's a mental technique we always
describe it as simple natural and
effortless easy to do and what you're
doing is a mental technique which allows
your mind and your body to slow down
I'm not a real focused person when I was
younger it was even worse I couldn't
even get through like a magazine article
without like losing my concentration I
think I've gone like recently way more
attached to my phone the time that I
used to spend just with myself and my
thoughts I now I'm like oh I have some
phone time now and so I think it'll just
cut out my phone time which is great I
have like big anxiety issue I'm
basically hoping that meditation would
help me boost my self-confidence I like
have a resting nice face but a lot of
times behind it it's just like panic so
my expectation is to be calmer and for
my mind to race less if I could do this
I'm very excited I really want it to
work I have to do it we're here at the
David Lynch foundation about to start
our first day of training I'm nervous
anxious last moment says just faced
terrible human being
Scot my mantra and yeah I feel really
call
I definitely feel tingly and felt like
such a release I like actually started
to cry a little bit I felt like I was on
the bottom of a pool at a party watching
a party go on above and being like super
calm and chilled out underneath of the
party that was really interesting I
didn't expect to go as deep as I did
right away I was thinking very visual
and there's a punk point where I was I
felt like I was flying in the wind I
think I'm gonna try drinking less
caffeine because I feel like when I have
tapped into my system it makes me like
harder to slow down my breathing then I
saw a guy with a huge mouth I'm hopeful
I have to say I'm hopeful and that feels
really good I just went into his mouth
and one each side and I was just pitch
black it's only been two days so very
curious to see the changes I could take
place over two months I've been pretty
good I've been really good probably some
of the best weeks of my life
I'm a little bit more like chipper my
mid-afternoon stress headaches went away
I feel much less anxious and I feel much
more like myself like I'm not like
faking being relaxed I like actually and
relaxed and I especially love meditating
with my cats
so last week I went camping by myself
and Joshua Tree I want off trails and I
started climbing boulders I got to the
top of really high boulders but one time
I could not go back down
she's pretty [ __ ] scary whoo
and it started to panic this drop I just
couldn't find a place to put my hands on
my feet and I couldn't go down if I just
jumped down I'm gonna die my heart's
beating really fast I could feel it and
that was really scared and I told myself
relax go meditate so literally I'm
meditating on top of the boulder
couple minutes later I open my eyes and
it felt so calm and easily I got back
down it really relieved my stress and my
worry it definitely helped save my life
I feel really good about Transcendental
Meditation meditation had a very
positive impact in my life I'm sad when
I don't meditate it makes me aware of my
own company that I can be alone and have
like a fulfilling time with myself when
I meditate I am much more in the now it
kind of puts more distance between me
finding something out and me freaking
out
there's like another option besides like
freak out and be stress you know I was
shy I'm not very confident my anxiety is
diminished and my ability to focus on
the task at hand is increased I think I
used to fill time with with like trash
content like Instagram or Twitter or
just constantly stimulating myself with
filler I think that I will continue
doing this indefinitely at least I hope
I do I want to keep doing it it's just
become so normal to me so part of my
routine I'm like spreading the gospel of
meditation to everybody it's just there
and I love it